in chopwell in gateshead winter brings a
harsh dilemma there are many vulnerable
and key worker children here who qualify
to attend school
but over populating the classroom
creates a risk
at a time the virus is rapidly spreading
through this town
all i know is that we've had corvette
kirsty coats a nurse has eight children
and seven of them tested positive for
covid19 over the christmas period
the virus could have been picked up at
one of their schools there was a lot of
talk about children
can't get it or don't get it as much
i've got
seven of mine out of eight i've all got
it
in different forms but they've all got
it it's no problem
for 18 month old jackson as you can tell
he's up in the window and everything but
his father stephen who is asthmatic
now has the virus and has just been
admitted to hospital
with breathing difficulties along with
the worry
kirsty is now homeschooling on her own
and how easy is it with
eight children to home school the simple
answer is it's not
um we do have the technology but it's
difficult
when i've got a six week old and an 18
month old
and then trying to share between three
rooms
new research by teacher tab shows demand
to attend primary schools
has doubled since the first lockdown a
wider definition of key workers and the
vulnerable
means more children are eligible can i
just ask those people in my
english group and a shortfall in laptops
promised by the government
means poorer children continue to
struggle with remote learning we've got
a third of what we were initially
expected
we've had to use school budget to buy
others to provide for the children and
the families who don't have them and we
still have a waiting list
the prime minister said this week over
600 000 devices have been provided to
schools since the pandemic but ofcom
estimates 1.5 million children are
without
and government guidelines for this
lockdown indicate that children who
don't have access to technology
can attend school so if all the kids who
didn't have laptops came in what would
that mean
i might as well just open my doors you
know we've
provided 30 i think so far
to a school of 180 in our mainstream
boat i've got to make this is safe for
the children who come in
and the safe for the teachers as well
another primary school in the gateshead
area kelvin grove sent a notice to
parents
saying classes are oversubscribed and is
exploring criteria for setting
caps on who can come in this pandemic
has served to remind us that schools
aren't just places of education
they offer help with social care
counseling
meals mental health support all things
that many children need
more than ever gateshead mom to lupe
cecile worries about her children's
development
her primary school isn't offering online
learning and what's more a native
nigerian she struggles to teach the
english phonics papers set by the school
and being on a low income heating and
food is another concern they keep
opening the fridge
like mom and we have snacks and we have
snacks
then there was a time i was asking them
do you hit like this in school
with increased demand on the fridge
several families who would normally be
taking their kids to chopwell primary
school
are instead queuing outside the
community center next door
here at the pickle palace you pay what
you can afford for leftovers from the
supermarkets
the working poor isn't it sort of
they're at that sort of level where the
conquest food bank but they still
struggle to sort of
you know fill the cupboards every week
or can i have a
turkey month please other local
charities agree the working poor and
their children
are being hardest hit by school closures
low income families
a lot of them they're in this band where
they miss out
on that support and that help they're
just over the barrier to getting things
like free school meal vouchers
they have to pay the increased demands
on gas and electric
themselves and they're on very very low
wages
this community in gateshead exemplifies
the problems facing the whole country
they're struggling with the lockdown but
they're also fearful
of the virus jason farrell sky news